Nicola Tesla believed that he could
harness the energy from inside the earth
and transmit that power wirelessly
around the world his early experiments
were successful but his research
mysteriously vanished after his death
there is no evidence left of Tesla's
Wireless power technology or is there
for years we were taught that the Great
Pyramid of Giza was a tomb for a king it
wasn't it had a different purpose Tesla
didn't invent Wireless power it's been
here for five thousand years and
probably a lot longer than that
foreign
why were the Pyramids built
uh dead mummies dead mummies
mainstream egyptology says that the
Great Pyramid of Giza is a tomb built
for Khufu the fourth Dynasty Egyptian
pharaoh who ruled 4 500 years ago but
the Great Pyramid doesn't have any
characteristics of other Egyptian tombs
the Great Pyramid contains no artifacts
no hieroglyphs and no elaborate wall art
it's been argued that the granite
sarcophagus found in the king's chamber
once contained khufu's mummy there's no
evidence that a mummy was ever there no
mummy has ever been found in any pyramid
ever ancient Egyptians considered their
Pharaoh's Gods the Great Pyramid is a
strange structure for God small Chambers
narrow shafts no markings at all the way
the pyramid was built and the materials
used to build it suggest it had a
different purpose the size of the
pyramid are aligned with the compass
with such accuracy that only modern
engineering can match it the Great
Pyramid is a mountain made of two and a
half million blocks of stone weighing 6
million tons piled 481 feet high its
footprint is over 13 acres to align this
construction within 1 15 of a degree of
True North is impossible Precision the
base of the Great Pyramid is leveled
within three quarters of an inch the
only way to do this with modern
structures is to use lasers even though
the sides of the pyramid are over 755
feet long made of stone blocks weighing
between 2 and 40 tons each each side is
within two inches of any other that's
99.98 accurate fun fact the pyramid
doesn't have four sides it actually has
eight each side is slightly concave that
you can only really see from directly
above or when the pyramid casts Shadows
during the equinoxes and yes those
angles too are perfect whoever built the
pyramids somehow knew the size of the
Earth if you take the height of the
pyramid and multiply it by 43 200 you
get
3938.685 miles which is within 11 miles
of the Polar radius of the planet that's
99.7 percent accurate if you take the
perimeter of the base of the pyramid and
multiply that by 43 200 you get 24
734.94 miles that's the Earth's
circumference at the equator with a 99.3
percent accuracy we know that the
Ancients were obsessed with equinoxes
when the day and the night are the same
lengths the length of the day and night
on an equinox is 43 200 seconds now
Skeptics will say this relationship
between forty three thousand two hundred
and the size of the Earth is forced they
say well the planet is different sizes
in different places so this is just a
coincidence no is this one of those
episodes where we make the Skeptics look
like idiots a little bit yeah oh good I
love those so close
hey
most of the Great Pyramid is constructed
of nomulite limestone the reddish brown
blocks that we see today this rock is
found close to the site and is abundant
but the Builders of the pyramid also use
unusual materials not found locally the
exterior of the pyramid was once covered
in casing stones made of bright white
Limestone they were polished smooth and
fit together so tightly that no seams
were visible these casing Stones were
cut and shipped from a quarry in Tura
almost 500 miles away that's like
carrying thousands of 10 ton stone
blocks the length of the entire State of
Florida they must have been special
unlike the Limestone cut locally tour
Limestone lacks magnesium this makes it
an excellent insulator Limestone can
carry an electrical current tour
Limestone can't interior Chambers were
built with a rare type of granite called
Rose Granite also brought from hundreds
of miles away this Granite has a high
concentration of silicon dioxide also
known as quartz when quartz is
compressed or even just moved it creates
a charge called piezoelectricity one
face of the quartz will have a positive
charge the other will have a negative
charge connect the two faces together
and you have an electrical circuit
because of this property quartz is used
in all kinds of modern devices like
watches clocks TVs GPS units and on and
on to charge a watch that uses quartz
all you have to do is shake it and if
you've ever used a barbecue lighter the
voltage is created by a quartz crystal
the king and queen's Chambers were built
with granite that is 85 quartz the
tunnels and passageways are also lined
with quartz Rich Granite if pressure was
applied to all this Granite it would
generate a tremendous amount of
electricity turning the pyramid into a
giant power plant and there's proof that
this is exactly what happened
the idea that the Great Pyramid was a
power plant is not new it was first
proposed in the 1970s it was and and is
considered a fringe Theory ooh those are
my favorite kind of theories I know the
fringing it better fringier fringier now
that doesn't sound right
um what's what's your problem oh I'm
sorry is the show interrupting your
train of thought the sarcasm nice but
what do you expect I'm trying to set up
the show here and it's so easy to do
when you're jumping in with common as
more and more discoveries were made over
the years more evidence emerged that the
Great Pyramid as a power plant wasn't
fringe science but actual science one of
the most compelling cases comes from
Christopher Dunn he believes the process
starts in the Subterranean chamber below
the pyramid are aquifers as water moves
through the underground cavities sound
waves are created the frequency of these
waves resonate with the Earth's natural
vibration as those waves move up through
the pyramid a process is used to magnify
focus and convert the sound into energy
the Queen's chamber was used for a
chemical reaction that created hydrogen
and there's substantial proof of this
there are two interior shafts that lead
to the Queen's chamber the northern
shaft has traces of hydrochloric acid
the southern has traces of hydrated zinc
chloride combining these two chemicals
creates a volatile reaction that
generates hydrogen a lot of hydrogen
this hydrogen gas would flow from the
Queen's chamber through the horizontal
passage and into the grand Gallery the
grand Gallery is also made of granite as
the hydrogen gas builds up the pressure
compresses the granite creating
electricity this electricity also
ionizes the air increasing conductivity
within the grand Gallery where 27 or 28
pairs of resonators that would vibrate
and emit sound the hydrogen atoms would
organize themselves into waves in
sympathy with the sound waves of the
gallery these sound waves further excite
the stone creating even more electricity
let me get this straight you stick the
shafts into the Queen's chamber which
gets the stones excited uh that's right
but somehow when you say it it sounds
dirty I'm a naughty naughty fish
acoustic Engineers have determined The
Gallery resonates at 440 Hertz and
naturally emits an F-sharp chord 440
Hertz and the F-sharp chord have been
connected to a lot of woo-woo ideas but
there's a reason for that it's
considered a sound that resonates in
harmony with the Earth the Builders of
the pyramid knew this longtime Mac users
will recognize this sacred chord
at the top of the gallery is a small
shaft leading to the king's chamber the
opening is 8.4 by 4.8 inches this is the
perfect size for hydrogen microwaves to
pass into the king's chamber which also
resonates at 440 Hertz and F-sharp above
the king's chamber are five layers of
granite beams stacked and separated by
air gaps this is called the relieving
chamber because it was believed that
this interior structure relieved the
weight of the pyramid
that's not what it does the beams are
smooth on three sides but rough cut on
the top Christopher Dunn believes the
reason for the rough cut is this is how
the beams were tuned the builders could
vibrate the granite beams and slowly
chip away at the stone until they
resonated with an F-sharp chord which
they do the king's chamber is what's
known as a helmholtz resonator when you
blow air across the top of a bottle and
create sound that's a helmholtz
resonator change the volume of liquid in
the bottle or change the volume of stone
within the chamber you change the pitch
the entire complex is a giant musical
instrument now some Skeptics reluctantly
agree that the Great Pyramid has musical
properties but for Skeptics to consider
the pyramid as a power plant they would
need evidence to show that a giant Stone
pyramid would respond to electromagnetic
energy there was no evidence of that
until 2018.
[Music]
whether true or not it's scientifically
possible that the Great Pyramid was a
Structure for creating harnessing and
focusing energy the exterior was made of
material that insulates electricity the
interior was made of material that
conducts electricity the chambers were
made of material that creates
electricity the next piece of evidence
is the pyramid's ability to focus em
energy in 2018 scientists use radio
waves at different frequencies to see if
the Great Pyramid would interact with
electromagnetic waves of a resonant
length their experiments proved that in
a resonant State the pyramid can
concentrate electromagnetic energy in
the internal Chambers as well as under
its base resonance in the pyramid can be
induced by radio waves with the lengths
ranging from 200 to 600 meters the
closer to 200 meters the more dramatic
the effect a year after that in 2019
Eric Wilson published a paper called a
large-scale thermal acoustic generator
the paper describes how when granite and
other Rock survive vibrated electrons
will migrate through the Rock and up to
the surface by combining science and
music the Builders of the pyramid
created a power generating machine tuned
to the Natural harmonic of the Earth's
vibration vibration that primarily comes
from the tidal energy created by the
moon's gravity this technology created
thousands of years ago could generate
unlimited clean energy but how did they
get the energy out that brings us back
to Tesla his werncleft Tower was built
on top of an aquifer with copper and
iron rods extending down into the water
when electricity was sent into the tower
it was to be transmitted around the
world through the atmosphere the pyramid
is also built on an aquifer and copper
pipes and iron rods have recently been
discovered there if the Capstone was
made of gold the energy concentrated
inside the pyramid would have been drawn
to the top and transmitted to the
atmosphere Tesla's Wireless power
distribution system used the Resonance
of the earth just like the pure pyramid
and just like the pyramid the energy
generated by Tesla's Tower would be
unlimited clean and virtually free for
everyone on the planet but Tesla's Tower
was destroyed by outside forces there's
evidence that the Great Pyramid was
destroyed from within
in the year 1900 Nikola Tesla convinced
JP Morgan to fund a project to create a
wireless communication system when Tesla
received the funding he decided to scale
up the project rather than transmit
messages around the world he would
transmit power Tesla had already
demonstrated that wireless power would
work on a small scale he famously had
light bulbs scattered on the ground that
would illuminate when a Tesla coil was
activated nearby now he wanted to go
bigger he explained this world-changing
technology to JP Morgan and asked him
for more money to complete the project
rather than support Tesla Morgan pulled
his funding claiming breach of contract
JP Morgan owned General Electric which
would be made obsolete he owned a t
which would also become obsolete JP
Morgan owned copper mines all over the
world and his factories generated miles
of copper wire JP Morgan owned rubber
farms and factories that created
insulation for wire he owned Steel
company companies and factories that
built power generators he owned Timber
Mills that created Telegraph and
electricity poles he owned coal mines
that fueled existing power plants and he
owned two dozen railroads that
transported all these resources around
the country none of this would be
necessary if Tesla created free
unlimited Wireless power for several
years Tesla wrote JP Morgan almost every
month begging him to reconsider he
wouldn't instead JP Morgan chose to
finance Tesla's competitors Edison and
Marconi who were improving on and
getting rich from Tesla's inventions and
not only the JP Morgan refuse any
further investment but he also put out
word to everyone in the wealthy investor
class that Tesla should be avoided it
was essentially blacklisted by 1915
Tesla had accumulated so much debt that
the bank foreclosed on the warden Cliff
property the tower was demolished in
1917 and sold for scrap the project was
never completed Tesla was a genius but
he was at a disadvantage men like Edison
and Marconi knew how to bring Tesla's
inventions to Market they knew how to
make technology accessible and most of
all they knew how to play the game you
don't bite the hand that feeds you
that's why 84 percent of the world's
energy is created from fossil fuels it's
also why Tesla died alone and broke
it's possible that the Great Pyramid
suffered some catastrophic event that
caused it to stop working in addition to
hydrochloric acid there are traces of
sulfuric acid in the southern shaft in
the northern shaft there's zinc chloride
and ammonium chloride these chemicals
can create hydrogen without being mixed
but if you do combine ammonium chloride
with sulfuric acid you get more than a
reaction you get an explosion because of
the structure of the pyramid this
explosion could be controlled but
there's evidence that an uncontrolled
explosion may have occurred in 2001 in
the grand Gallery Scorch marks were
discovered in the ceiling above where
the resonators would have been in the
king's chamber cracks have been found in
the granite beams at first this was
thought to be caused by an earthquake
but the damage was only found in areas
of the pyramid where the flow of Highly
compressed heated hydrogen occurred the
walls in the king's chamber have been
pushed out over an inch it takes a lot
of pressure to push tons of granite out
that far the great step outside the
king's chamber also shows extensive
damage like that from an explosion not
an earthquake other parts of the
Interior also show signs of charring
when the southern shaft was discovered
it was coated with salt about an inch
thick this would happen if hydrogen was
boiling and bubbling up the shaft what
caused The Pyramid Power Plant to
explode is not known but Christopher
Dunn believes it was some sort of
cataclysm not an earthquake but maybe an
asteroid impact there's a problem with
this Theory though the ancient Egyptians
kept meticulous records of everything
there is no record of an impact during
this time Dunn believes it happened
thousands of years earlier and that
brings me to this thought Skeptics will
say if the ancient Egyptians used
electricity there would be documentation
even hard evidence of it you'll see True
Believers point to glyphs that look like
light bulbs but I honestly think that's
a stretch there's no evidence the
Egyptians worked with glass or any
components used to make light bulb so
why is there no evidence of the use of
electricity in ancient Egypt and no
record of electricity being generated by
the Great Pyramid well because the
ancient Egyptians didn't build it
[Music]
there really is no debate by mainstream
academics about the who when why or how
the Great Pyramid it was built by
ancient Egyptians in 4500 BC as a tomb
for Khufu and that's that but what if
none of that is true what if the ancient
Egyptians didn't build the Pyramid but
found it and when they found it it had
been dormant for years maybe thousands
of years Graham Hancock is a proponent
of the Orion constellation Theory this
says the Great Pyramid complex is almost
a perfect match for the stars in the
Orion constellation but they don't line
up to where Orion is today they line up
with where Orion was in the sky 13 500
years ago we've discussed how the
builders were obsessed with equinoxes
the Sphinx faces due east and on the
vernal equinox the constellation that
Rose due east 13 500 years ago was Leo
now I'll concede the astronomical
evidence could be a coincidence but
there is hard evidence that these
structures are old than originally
thought you can't carbon date Limestone
but there are clues that the pyramid and
the Sphinx have been there for a long
long time Robert shock from Boston
University believes the Sphinx and Giza
complex is about 13 500 years old Giza
has been an extremely dry climate since
the time of the Pharaohs but the Sphinx
show signs not only of wind and sand
erosion but also extreme water erosion
the erosion patterns around the base of
the Sphinx could only occur if huge
volumes of water are washing over the
plateau at violent speeds there's
evidence this happened at the end of the
younger dryas which marked the end of
the last ice age in 9700 BC glaciers
were thought to have melted rapidly
within a few centuries sea levels Rose
500 feet this is fast in geologic time
but as more evidence was gathered
melting appeared to happen in a matter
of decades this would cause dramatic
changes in the earth's climate but when
recent ice core samples were studied
things got even more dramatic there's
evidence that the last ice age didn't
end over centuries or decades but ended
in one single day
some claim that an asteroid impact
caused the last ice age to end a
worldwide disaster like the chick
shiloom impact that wiped out the
dinosaurs that's not what happened an
impact causes cooling recent studies
show that there was a major solar event
that happened around 9700 BC basically
the mother of all CMEs a violent plasma
storm hit the earth and overwhelmed the
Earth's magnetosphere which is our
defense against solar radiation without
the protection of the magnetosphere
massive lightning strikes happened all
over the Earth lightning that was orders
of magnitude more intense than anything
we've ever seen this lightning was
hundreds or even thousands of times more
powerful than anything from a
thunderstorm there's evidence in over
120 countries of rock melted and turned
to Glass during this event this is
called vitrification there's evidence of
vitrification in moon rocks we know for
a fact large mammals like saber-toothed
tigers and woolly mammoths were wiped
out at this time they didn't slowly go
extinct they instantly went extinct
during the four or five days of this
event the Earth was also Awash in Lethal
radiation only animals that can go
underground survived most of the human
race died during this event only humans
living near caves were able to find
shelter and survive if glaciers which
covered 30 percent of the Earth's
surface melted in a day or two think of
the speed volume and pressure of water
that would rush across the Earth's
surface this water would act like a
power washer on Stone constructions like
the Sphinx and pyramids meanwhile A Sky
Full of plasma and lightning and
radiation would have severely damaged
the Great Pyramid if it was using a
volatile chemical reaction to create
power every culture has a flood myth
that served as a reset of civilization
all those stories seemed to point to a
cataclysm at the end of the younger
dryas myths of lost continents like
Atlantis also fit into this timeline now
I'm not claiming any anything I've said
today is what happened but I am saying
there's evidence that it was possible
that an advanced civilization existed
thousands of years ago that Civilization
had the technology to create unlimited
clean energy then the glaciers melted a
great flood came solar plasma and
radiation destroyed a significant amount
of life on the planet the civilization
then disappeared then thousands of years
later as the great Egyptian culture was
forming they would have utilized the
pyramid not for power but for ceremonial
or religious purposes they would have
altered the Sphinx carving away the
original design and replacing it with a
design of their own and we know this is
what they did mainstream scientists are
still not convinced and that's okay as
time goes on and more secrets are
revealed sooner or later we will learn
the truth and I suspect we'll learn that
the pyramid power plant theory was right
all along
[Music]
whoever built the pyramids created
energy that wasn't harmful to the Earth
but resonated in harmony with it a
suspicious person might wonder why if
this theory has been around for 50 years
nobody's tried to replicate it even on a
small scale unlimited clean energy for
everyone on Earth sounds like a way for
the entire human race to take a huge
step forward think of the technological
advances that could be made if
electricity was free think of the
political Strife economic instability
and the endless Wars that could be
avoided but maybe what's happening now
is what happened to Tesla a hundred
years ago in Tesla's time nobody was
interested in creating technology that
would make Power free for everyone
Empires owned by JP Morgan the
Vanderbilts and the Rockefellers would
have been devastated the carnegies the
duponts and the melons all would have
seen significant losses these families
owned all the energy production and
distribution in the United States their
companies were the lifeblood of American
industry the fam families were American
royalty if Tesla was able to achieve his
vision Not only would the wealth of
these families be diminished so would
America's standing in the world as a
great new industrial power Tesla said he
wanted to bring abundant electrical
energy to remote underdeveloped parts of
the world to Foster closer communication
between nations this couldn't be allowed
to happen America and the corporations
that controlled it would never have
given up their advantage they still
won't when Tesla died the FBI and agents
of the OSS were for some reason close by
Tesla's documents were stored in 80
boxes all organized and numbered by
Tesla himself only 60 boxes were
discovered and since then a few
scientists have stated that Tesla's
invention would have never worked but
that's what scientists said of most of
his inventions viewers of this channel
know that most science is bought and
paid for by corporations and governments
this is especially true in the last
couple of years
jib right another jab another jab
another yep what are those Jabs work or
not you human pincushions are making
people Rich oh there's no doubt about
that eighty percent of the products we
use today can be traced back to Tesla
but the technology that we really need
now more than ever is inexpensive clean
energy sadly that technology died with
Tesla instead the world went in the
direction of coal and oil and Nations
fought and continue to fight Wars to
control these limited resources oil coal
and War may be terrible for the planet
and the people who live on it but
they're great for business and for all
his genius that's something Nikola Tesla
never understood
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment and share I hate
to give you homework but that stuff
really helps and like most topics we
cover on the channel today's topic was
recommended by you and if there's a
story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips and
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible we couldn't do it
without you and if you'd like to support
the y-files consider becoming a member
on patreon or grabbing something from
the Wi-Fi store the cheapest Bowl topped
off with vodka ain't cheap no it's not
I'd like to upgrade from Stoli to
Belvedere don't push it that's gonna do
it until next time be safe be kind and
know that you are appreciated I gotta
sneeze
couldn't get couldn't get it
gesundheit
[Music]
thank you